sports like football are often great
unifiers transcending race religion and
nationality in our ongoing series a more
perfect union we highlight how what
connects us as Americans is deeper than
what divides us this morning we have a
great story from Gallaudet University in
Washington DC I love this story Janice
Crawford is on campus with how its
football team the Bison tackles lessons
beyond the field Jan good morning
well good morning so you know this is an
historic campus me President Lincoln's
sign Gallaudet's original charter back
in 1864 when the Civil War was raging on
and recently this private university has
been integrating students with diverse
life experiences and the football team
really symbolizes that I mean this is a
story about the power of communication
whatever happens you don't stop
believing today football is equal parts
passion dedication and teamwork
but this gameday feels different and
quieter than most
the cheerleaders perform the national
anthem with no music and no singing just
hand gestures signaling that our flag
was still there and with that the
Gallaudet University bison America's
deaf team as they call themselves take
on
annamaria am cats doesn't matter you
know you're deaf hard of hearing hearing
and the other team they're showing up to
play a game like see how the games
change remember the highs and the lows
we discussed coach Chuck Goldstein has
to lead the team without doing what
coaches do yelling or blowing a whistle
sometimes I see the whistle will go
early
but our player doesn't hear and he runs
like 90 yards and he turns around go
back the first thing you do the Bison
communicate using ASL or American Sign
Language you can't hear the snap count
we just like watch the football the
quarterback he taps the center and we
just go win a football snap so you watch
the ball watch the ball wide receiver LJ
Watson speaks and signs a technique
called a simcom at first he and his
heart of hearing teammates
Daquan Taylor and Rashard Witherspoon
had a tough time seeing eye to eye my
team chemistry was hard
the chemistry it's like hard to
communicate with each other because some
players on the team don't know sign
half of the players are deaf others are
hard of hearing and to have enough
players to compete each year coach
Goldstein integrates into the team a few
mainstream hearing athletes our
recruiting pool is limited it's limited
so it's kind of a struggle we have
people who are looking online everyday
for deaf hard of hearing athlete going
google try no that's how they find
players like Taylor a defensive stand
out from Hampton Virginia where sports
of religion but Taylor thought he had
blown his chance to play college ball
didn't work out like no scholarship
after see the mistakes partying strike
the girls grades then he got an
opportunity to join the Bison so how I
fell in love on my visit it was like
deaf people they knew I couldn't sign
but they still said to me it was an
unfamiliar feeling for Taylor whose
mother died when he was in the seventh
grade
he spent his teenage years bouncing
around different friends homes now a
junior sign language comes as easily to
Taylor as football Gallaudet was a shot
at redemption and now you're gonna
graduate you're gonna have a degree
really help me become a man where I'm
from is like a bad area jail
did you sell drugs honestly
so when guy you did like gave me a
chance to like play football I was like
I'm not like risking it again I'm not
these roommates are a testament to the
power of communicating without saying a
word why are you guys coming from your
different backgrounds able to come
together and communicate and succeed
because we have patience with each other
patience and you know we're willing to
slow things down
just became close became brother it's
like we're his brothers on the football
team but like now us three is different
we can understand each other a lot like
not saying nothing today about 12% of
Gallaudet students can hear and going
forward the school is going to have to
continue blending these different
communities and redefining itself
without sacrificing its identity how
maybe the football team can help pave
the way Gail
all right Jenn that sounds like a movie
to me I wonder if there's anybody in the
green room that knows anything about
making movies he's looking for
somebody's back they're a very great
story Thank You Jan